my surrogacy. And he called me about my surrogacy yesterday. And he was talking about the
lips and the exercises that are in the notebook. We don't have a rebounder but I was wondering
if there was another exercise that I could use that both Mike and I could use together
walking or biking or you know whatever. Yeah so the idea of helping, helping live phatic
congestion is in order for live to move through the live vessels it requires contraction of
muscles. So if I do eat anything that will help that will involve contraction of muscles is going to
help with live flow. The other problem with live congestion isn't the flow of the live
it is the stasis of the extra cellular the fluid outside of the cells it's the stasis of that
and not able for it to get into the live vessels. So when a person has quote unquote live phatic
congestion there's two possible problems happening. What is that? They're not moving. So if I have a
job that all I do is sit all day and I walk to the car drive home and come home and sit on the couch
and I'm not doing any contraction of muscles or very little I could get swelling in the
quote unquote live phatic congestion and it's because I'm not using my muscles. Another person
could be doing a whole bunch of exercise but they still have a lot of live phatic congestion
and it's because of the the extra cellular that means the outside of your cell
that you can get a protein matrix that binds up and it basically the fluid between the cells gets
kind of cloggy gets congested gets gets thick gets viscous and it's not able to get into the
into the live system very well. Well that's where motion will help with that too.
Increasing water intake will help with that and you know vibration helps with that so like a
vibration plate will help with that. But something to do together if it's like I get in some swelling
and I feed I want to just keep my lymph flowing. I'd say you really start with just going out walking
and swinging your arms and moving your body get out gardening get out doing some things outside.
Yes I'm pretty active you know we used to walk you know you have to run 5k and it's on to walking
so but we have a farm though we are very active like the dead gardening I don't sit around all day
but I was just wanting to try to find something that that we could do together
because we like to do things together. That's good. And he needs to exercise as well as I do.
Yeah that's good. I'd say get out walking make sure you're trying to swing your arms and do a
little kind of you don't have to go fast but kind of a race walk look you know where you're doing more
of an exaggerated step not the whole time but at some times so your moving you're trying to
contract as many different muscles as possible. Okay is that being weight help? Sure because you're just
anything that's contracted muscles that's going to help. Okay all right I can do that.